I've got a so this is a tweet from
Richard ebite who uh was one of the um
virologists who was kind of I mean one
of the earliest people I remember
raising this possibility of it being a
lab leak um and he calls this this
invoice for this particular enzyme that
Alex mentions in his study this is an
order form uh for it and he calls it the
equivalent of a Smoking Gun on the other
hand uh Alina Chan who is another uh
someone who's been very uh um sort of
putting out the idea of that this could
have been a loud leag for a long time
we've had her on the show before she
co-authored a whole book uh about the
origins of covid with Matt Ridley called
viral um and she's not convinced yet she
says there isn't enough yet to say a lab
accident happened Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt uh mostly because the emails and
documents we're talking about are from
early 2018 so therefore it's
unsurprising there's not any direct
evidence of you know a line from this
this order to the creation of SARS COV 2
you know I guess an an open question
that I have for both of you is how
should we evaluate evidence and like
when when is the appropriate time to say
you know case closed this is you know
this is the Smoking Gun we can pretty
much say at this point we're never going
to get 100% certainty but beyond A
Reasonable Doubt looks like something
something happened here something was
constructed I'm happy to jump in here I
think you know what I was doing before
Co was specifically forecasting which
species are Quasi species that are junk
capable what's the likelihood of that
emerging where is it likely to emerge um
and what does that look like and we all
have actually seen a recent example of a
natural spillover with the Aven
influenza outbreaks that happened last
year many people got infected and you
see these stuttering chains of
transmission because exactly as Emily
said the virus was not very
transmissible when it first jumped into
the human population and so for me what
jumped out is like you know we'll put a
line way over here for case closed and
then there's a line way over here for
open the books and I think we cross the
open the books line immediately when
SARS K2 emerged it had a receptor
binding domain that was better at
binding humans than bats that's a really
unusual feature for a bat Corona virus
viruses specialize on their host they
get these very specific moldings of
their Spike genes The receptors of their
host The receptors of bats are different
from humans so this should be molded to
a bat but instead it looked more molded
to a human than a bat so that was
immediately a very strange occurrence
that it didn't have this multiple
spillover events across a wide
Geographic range consistent with the
animal trade outbreak of SARS one there
were not infections concentrated in
animal handlers like we saw in civit
handlers in SARS one or in poultry
Farmers for Aven influenza instead it
was this singular outbreak that just
exploded immediately out of Wuhan with a
SARS Corona virus whose receptor binding
domain was better fit for humans than
bats that had a fear and cleavage site
that as someone again in this Wildlife
virology Community I knew that many
virologists were fixated on Fair and
cleavage sites this was something that
biologists thought a lot about but when
you look at the data in nature nature
did not stumble upon it that often
instead it would it happened we look
made a big deal out of it wrote big
papers about it and everyone was aware
of it but nature was not and so for me
it we crossed the line to open the books
almost immediately at the start of the
pandemic but there's never been that
that's never seemed to have been the
attitude um you know opening the books
uh it it would what would follow from
that is you know open scientific this is
a this is an empirical question it's so
that that requires open scientific
inquiry but I you know I think to kind
of capture the tone of that we can just
look at these tweets from uh Christian
Anderson who was uh one of the authors
on the famous proximal Origins paper
that uh proposed that this jump from
pangolins to humans uh that Pengalin
were the intermediate host and then um
it was revealed through documents that
he had these kind of this back Channel
with Anthony fouchi who was sort of
guiding that project the entire time but
his reaction to your uh preprint Alex
was that uh it is so deeply flawed that
it wouldn't pass kindergarten molecular
biology it's more of the same poppycock
dressed up as science with a heavy dose
of technobabble on the side and you know
you don't have to reply to that kind of
name calling though you can if you want
what I'd like to know is um what are the
challenges for dissenting scientists at
this point in examining the this
question obviously there's been
challenges along the way but like at
this point do you feel that your paper
could even get a fair peer review or is
the process itself kind of
compromised well a couple points here
one yeah the feedback from Christian
Anderson was not the most constructive
feedback we
received um another little aside my mom
was a molecular biologist so in
kindergarten I was doing some you know
listening about DNA at the table but not
that much admittedly um and then finally
you know a lab origin involves a lab and
the lab involves researchers and
researchers are in this network of
colleagues and funders and so when we
pass this open the books phase very
early on in the pandemic we would have
liked to hear about for example The
diffus Proposal but did we hear about
the diffuse proposal no we didn't um did
we hear the niid had actually funded the
unique collaboration of the diffused pis
in 2019 no we didn't instead Anthony
fouchy helped prompt that proximal
origin paper Peter dasac the pi of
diffuse wrote a paper to the Lancet
calling lab origin theories conspiracy
theories without acknowledging the
conflict of interest that he was working
with the lab in question that he wrote
The diffus Proposal containing a highly
specific proposal to make something not
found in nature something so unnatural
that you could have patented it in 2018
and SARS KOB 2 would be an infringement
of their patent that's a very important
conflict of interest he should have
disclosed when we were at the open the
books phase in January of 2020 and he
didn't just to follow up on a couple of
the things that um Alex was mentioning I
think in addition to the scientific
evidence that we dug up and that he dug
up I think it's also important to look
at the behavioral Clues here and the odd
um actions of people sort of central to
the coronavirus research going on in
Wuhan after Source kov 2 emerged from
that city um including the fact that
Beric was working on this model that was
meant to predict whether a Corona virus
could cause disease in humanized mice
using um you know the receptor binding
domain's ability to bind to human Ace 2
and fear and cleavage sites and then
when SARS kovy 2 with this these unique
features showed up did not raise his
hand to say I actually have a model you
know I've been studying this for years
um you know silence for sure yeah
absolutely yes and um and why did daik
continue to insist for years that this
work would go on at the University of
North Carolina under a bsl3 when clearly
he knew you know he wrote this comment
saying saying that in fact this work
would be outsourced to the Wuhan
Institute of Urology and would be
conducted under bsl2 yeah let me pull
that up uh this is from those those
documents so uh yeah you you got the the
annotated comments on um their proposal
and so here you've got uh um Peter daac
saying that you know if we win the
contract I am not proposing that all the
work will necessarily be conducted by
Ralph baric in North Carolina but he
wants to stress the US side of the
proposal to DARPA so that they're
comfortable in in other words he wants
to play Down the fact that as he says a
lot of these this work can be done in
Wuhan um and then further down you've
got Ralph baric uh talking about their
proposal to in China do this in a
biocurity level two rather than the
higher biocurity level three that would
be expected the US and he says that you
know um if they're they're growing those
in under bsl2 in China us researchers
will likely freak out and so yeah there
there's really that it's very revealing
of the the the mindset and and the
culture of like I mean these are people
who have a a really serious
responsibility of handling a virus that
can kill lots of people and just just
societal destruction and they're kind of
like what can we slip past DARPA and and
again luckily DARPA did not approve this
particular Grant but it does say a lot
about kind of the atmosphere uh what
what was the the Cavalier attitude of
the scientists that are are working with
these these really deadly uh da
dangerous viruses but Emily uh continue
with your your explanation of the the
psychology and then if you could also
talk a little bit about the media
coverage of the lab leak at
present yeah I mean I think your your
spot on there I mean Beric said that us
researchers would freak out about this
work being outsourced to bsl2 in China
before uh you know virus um started
circulating the globe um out of Wuhan so
um of course he knew people would freak
out about this um and instead of doing
what I think would be the moral
patriotic thing and being transparent um
and coming forward uh they attempted to
save their own reputations and clearly
dazak made a bet that these documents
would never come out and so he kept
lying to his sources in um in media and
lying to other scientists that this work
was to be done in um more rigorous
biosafety standards of the US and he
knew that to be a lie um he also said
that they didn't sample in LA and that
was also a lie you know some of SARS kov
2's closest relatives circulate in
southeast China so that's highly
relevant information to the origins of
covid um and people looked in genbank
and said it says that this this was
sampled in La what's going on um and our
documents also confirm their intention
to sample there so um so the behavior is
very strange the Lancet letter
organizing that and telling Ralph barck
to leave his name off um
it's you know I think that speaks
volumes as well and then also I did want
to answer your original question about
what is what would constitute kind of
final firm evidence I think the um the
research described and the documents
that we and drastic
obtained um probably describe how SARS
kov 2 became SARS kov 2 but we don't
know what viruses they were starting
with we don't know at the time they were
exchanging these notes and having these
conversations if they had sampled SARS
K2 like viruses at that point um you
know we know they uh have identified
rg-33 one of SARS kov 2's closest
relatives um but I think we need to know
more information about that but if we
were to confirm that they were doing
using some of the techniques described
in these doc ments with SARS K2 like
viruses I think that would be I mean as
close to like a final Smoking Gun as you
could get hey thanks for watching that
clip from our new show just asking
questions you can watch another clip
here or the full episode here new
episodes drop every week so subscribe to
reent TV's YouTube channel to get
notified when that happens or to the
just asking questions podcast on Apple
Spotify or any other podcaster see you
next week